Google Cloud recently announced exciting
new generative AI capabilities Palm 2
for text and chat is now available to
everyone through vertex AI let's take a
look at four ways you can tune these
models you can access these models in
generative AI Studio where you can
interact with them through a chat
interface and easily deploy them prompt
tuning is an efficient low-cost way of
customizing the foundation model without
retraining it prompts are how we guide
the model to generate useful output
using natural language rather than a
programming language fine tuning is the
process of further training the model on
new data resulting in changes to the
model's weights this is helpful for use
cases that require outputs with
specialized results like legal or
medical vocabulary you can also adjust
model parameters to improve the quality
of responses try different models and
select the temperature top p and top K
these are parameters that let you adjust
the randomness of responses parameter
efficient tuning is a super exciting
research area that aims to reduce the
challenges of fine tuning by only
training a small subset of parameters
check out the link in our description to
learn more and take a deeper dive into
all the generative AI announcements from
IO